today's topic all right so I'm gonna
read out a story for you today cuz this
is a great story Oh third time my ex got
his act together after we divorced my
husband and I were together for 10 years
married for six no kids we eventually
grew apart and that is to say I grew up
and he didn't he wanted to live the life
of a teenager well into his 30s the last
two three years together we were
horrible after his dad passed away he
gained all this weight lost his job I
tried to help and support him but he
would just wallow in self-pity and
stopped pitching in around the house he
spent all his free time smoking weed and
eating around on the computer he had to
sell his junk car to pay your bills
eventually had enough and we got a
divorce in 2015 were essentially been no
contact since it was finalized last
Friday I happen to bump into him
downtown and he's completely different
person he lost all the weight he put on
had actually toned up some he was
wearing a tailored suit he had an
ill-fitting one for weddings and
funerals while we were together
it's a little petty and he had a nice
watch he may have gotten hair plugs or
something because his thinning hair
wasn't as pronounced as before he told
me he bought a condo nearby within
walking distance of his new job a
well-known tech firm in her town our
encounter was brief and he was nice to
me he even apologized for how our
relationship soured and wished me all
the best it's been four days since I saw
him and honestly I just get angrier the
more I think about it I gave the ten
best years of my life to this man and
got nothing from it we never had kids he
never had much money when we divorced
I started from square one now he's mr.
successful while I'm struggling my job
is very stressful and I'm making less
than I was five years ago
I live alone and money is tight I've
been having some intestinal digestive
issues and doctors don't seem to know
what's wrong with me I guess I won't
just want to know why he couldn't have
been better to me and why I wasn't even
worth the effort
oh that was not love that was a
transaction I can't really put the
finger on it but you are mad because
he's in a better place man is not love
well she's wondering why he couldn't
have been in a better place when they
were together could be being faked time
you left you decided to end the
relationship that's what you said well
they were married for 10 years I'm not
saying no 10 years still 10 years a long
time 10 years is a long time for someone
to be yeah it is do you think somebody's
gonna stay with somebody who's up for 10
years expecting them to turn it around
10 years I'm not expecting that but I
mean you got married in the valley says
for better or for worse that is the
worst about minutes of the violence Judy
it's an engagement that you have with
someone maybe a lot is sense and then
ask what it means or maybe I'm being too
literal with this yes 10 years is a lot
but when you think for better or for
worse that's the worse that is part of
it it could have been worse than that
that's a part of it I understand why she
left I get it you knew what you were
getting yourself into when you married
the dude in the first place
did she I don't know maybe that's not
what she was advertised maybe I know
people who get into a marriage thinking
is one thing then they get married
people get comfortable and they take
everything for granted it's possible you
know what I'm gonna give it to you we
don't know fair but you walk out he
feels better you're mad because he feels
better that's gonna be me I don't think
she's mad that he feels better she's mad
that she was hoping he would do all
those things while they were together
and it seems like the moment she's out
the picture now he's doing all the
things that she wished he would have
done the human brain is really weird to
function it takes weird slap in the face
for you to realize okay maybe you were
enabling him I don't know I was not in
the relationship you leaving him was
maybe the thing that he needed to get
obviously you were there I supported him
I support him and I gave and I gave it I
gave maybe that's
it was maybe he needed you to get the
[ __ ] out of there sometimes you need to
reach bottom of the barrel rock bottom
gelfoam Peter deep you need to reach the
bottom bottom is it logic no if you
meant so maybe her leaving was the thing
that he needed is this sad yeah is it
unfortunate absolutely poor you but it
is what it is
entitlement about that I'm uneasy about
I can't really put my finger on it I let
our partner on that and I'll let you
finish just go I'll come back on that
alright here's a truth him changing
after you dumped it is not a big
surprised you were the catalyst
potentially or maybe something after you
was the catalyst but you can't hope to
be the catalyst and the beneficiary if
you were what brings about change that
change may not benefit you I'll give you
an example
you have kids they grew up to be adults
sometimes they don't learn the
importance of responsibility until they
leave the nest sometimes they don't
develop into real human beings and real
adults until they're out of their
parents is home maybe that person needed
to leave in order to realize what they
needed to do for themselves to grow when
you're in a place of comfort where you
know nothing's gonna go wrong
you don't have too much incentive to
change so when he was in a comfortable
relationship with you
odds are he felt like I could be
complacent because I'm always gonna have
this girl my back and when that was
removed from under him he had to
reassess some things second thing that
strikes me is that I'll try to put this
in business terms when you invest in a
company and it goes nowhere like what he
said earlier it's your choice to invest
in that company you pull out and then
after you pull out the invest off if the
company takes off well booboo you
already sold your shares it's over
that's your cut investment you don't get
a return on investment that was business
when it comes to people I feel like it's
very similar you know at the end of the
day what he said wasn't totally off when
you marry somebody you marry them as
they are because you grow doesn't mean
someone's gonna grow at the same rate as
you right you said something I thought
it was interesting which was
when we met to get we got together
things were great but I grew past him
and he never grew up even to his 30s he
kept all these bad habits your speed of
growth may not be his speed of growth we
all grow differently and so the fact
that he didn't grow at your pace that's
the reality I have friends from high
school who I love but the reality is we
grew apart because they didn't grow at
the same pace or in different directions
than I did I'm not gonna look at them
like why haven't you guys joined me in
this they have their journey it's not a
race it's a marathon
how long can my last people can grow
apart and that's a normal process that
process does it mean that one person
messed up or the other one did it we all
have our journeys even within
relationships that's a reality he's 37
or 34 so I bet you guys got married when
you were around 24 and 27
that's young too young too young
professionally we're not established as
adults and human beings were not
completely sure of who we are yet for
you guys to get married that young will
be surprised that you're growing apart
it's not surprising to me right so
that's the other thing to consider and
the last thing is your unhappiness with
your current situation has nothing to do
with him if you're in a relationship you
come out of it you have all this time
afterwards and things don't go well or
go the way that you want and you see
they're going well for him you're like
what happened why didn't you boo-boo you
should be focused on your situation and
if your situation was better I guarantee
you wouldn't be mad at the progress that
he made this life you mad because you
didn't do everything that you needed to
do to set yourself up and now you're
looking for outside excuses for why your
circumstances suck so much oh this guy I
couldn't believe you did this to me why
is he doing better now a selfish you're
comparing yourself that's selfish if you
aren't in a good place that's your fault
if you after three four or five years of
marriage is done now and you haven't
gotten to a better place that's your
fault you're bitter you're angry and
you're seeing somebody who used to be
beneath you be ahead of you by your own
standards and you're mad because you
could have had a piece of that its
entitlement you left because you didn't
want to date down
if we want to be super petty yeah that's
what it is but now that he caught up to
you and surpassed you now he doesn't
want to be in the same position you were
in maybe that's what it is that's what
bothers me
you left cuz you dated down he surpassed
you what he's like a well I started
about before no hard feelings I'm out he
wouldn't do that you're pissed hmm
because he took the same position that
you did he's at the position where when
you live that hmm he's the ideal man you
would have wanted for your dream life
and you're realizing you missed out on
that but then you know there's something
else that she said that was interesting
she said I gave him 10 best years of my
life meaning she already feels like
she's past her prime well that's how
society makes me feel sure but that's
how she also feels I know women who are
in their mid-30s and feel great about
the soul yeah so that's not an excuse
it's not right and so if you're thinking
that way then of course you're not gonna
attract anything positive so boom you
have the ability to change a lot you
know we live in a place where women can
make just as much as men you guys can do
the work you guys can create your own
opportunities you could ask man now you
can do all this stuff if your life is
not going the way you want it to it's
not because your ex was a deadbeat it's
because it's your fault the fact that
you stayed with him for ten years that's
your fault the fact that you're bitter
right now that's your fault all this to
say there's no point in wallowing in
this and the fact that you're angry
about it is you're not angry at him
you're angry at yourself for not doing
what you needed to do there's something
to set yourself or something on Matthew
about that about being angry about her
and being angry she's bitter she's
bitter about life only somebody who's
bitter about a life would get mad that
Mike's is doing well I wasn't straight
on yourself yeah if they focus be yeah
even if he wasted a lot of years with
you you decided to stay in that
relationship you should have cut bait
wait earlier when you focus on yourself
you're in competition with people that
you don't even know you're in
competition with and now you're in that
position he doesn't even know he's a
competition he's just an ex and he's
sorry about what he did before focus so
if you got bitter feelings about your ex
if somebody you left
you're doing way better you're like oh
my god I'm stop just focus on your own
stuff do better for yourself I had a
girl who did that to me she was upset
that I got my
upset that she got you together see that
again you think right he got upset that
you got you together so when I wasn't
doing much had no money my name nothing
else she didn't think it was a good
prospect then I started figuring stuff
out and she's like oh you really come in
and she try to slide back in you know
what I'm saying I was like nah I don't
need no that but I just remember her
being like man I wish it would have been
like this a couple of years back it took
me this whole journey to get to this
place it took me this long it took my
results didn't just come here it takes
time that's it you know so you got to
work on that I mean I didn't get mad
about it yeah so all this to say guys
man or woman just don't be bitter it
really doesn't do you any justice and if
you're feeling angry about something
like that
you don't have to beat yourself up over
it just don't give it energy it's not
real unless you start [ __ ] doing
stuff about it all right you got a
little bit of ego your egos bruised keep
moving start working on stuff that'll
pass give you more power to work on you
exactly I hope it gives you more fuel to
work on you because girls staying and
dwelling on that it's not good events
it's not gonna advance your predicament
whatever so tell us what you guys think
in the comments below we want to hear
your input what do you guys think about
this story
[Music]